こちら弾み撮影です皆さん10行か
ぞ
皆さん遊戯王カードとしていますか知らないありがとうございます授業カードというの
は昔からあるトレーディングカードゲームがことです
僕もね校中学校高校とハマってたんですけど最近ねちょっと目覚めちゃって
今日ですねなんとですね近くのセブンイレブンで授業カードばすごい全部半額だっ
たってお店の中の予定
7を買ってきましたゆデーそんな枚数があるわけじゃないんですけど結構地味にあり
ますまあちょっと本格的に有料化本だけ言ってるじゃないっすよガチ勢じゃないんだ
けどこ
趣味てんだ乳業カードができたらなと思っでまあそういう低位な理由でちゃって優良
カードナンバーけど全部で46パックこちらにわかっちゃいました40のパック4個
彼は決してお金の無駄とは思ってません
じゅ演出ですか神これだけ回だの良かったんですねばあまり乗っていうことなんで
ちょっと不安があるんですけど店にあった授業カード全部買ってきたんだよ
開封していこうと思いますでねっ知らずに上げても面白くないからある程度スタビーを
してきました
こちらにあるパックは8種類あります舌オブザライト
27パック浴びせ第二ング12パックシャドウスペクターズ
ドロップ up そのブレイザーが入っパックですうよ母と月やってる人から見たら
こいつ何言ってるかって感じなんですけど
初心者に猫調べたねまぁそこらへんはご了承ください
今ば一緒にウイズ目指そうというわけでまずはこちらの一番多いニーズあパッカーて
judge of the ライトについ
通称勢大 t l パッケージになっているボスは希望校ホープレイヴィクトリー
ぐらいに抱える少女をつかめカオスエクシーズチェンジ希望校ほどデビッドいい
てわけですねまぁ希望広報文ビクトリーがまあ一番もあったりで
次は星態龍あと機皇帝ギャラクシーのペアと利用と春休やって言う
まぁここらへんを狙っていけばいいよって言うネットでの情報ですま
ひとによって欲しい方違うから何とも言えないんですけど一般的にはこのカードがあれ
ばグッドって活用シーンで上げていこうと思いますこのホープレイヴィクトリー停滞で
下落しの領土春9件以外はさんのせませんかつ飯綱のパックズバーってざいます
こいつだねコイツが一番いいやつです
を割くべきよ
そのためだやばいちょっと寺しかあんまりよろしくない感じです
これもだめだ山々下ひょっとしてこれ
スーツとかしてやるのかん
ズンとも言えないなんですか
タッカ指定なこのでだってさという検知しながら切るのはいいんだよね
全然大ジャンプその日
されたお星ヤマトって継がせました
強いだろうかわかんないけど光ってるからねばいいんでしょうけど
これ絶対おかしいでしょ
を思帆方もここ行きバスで来ました来ました
今回 victory を打ってやってない
ええええええ
名3どんどん行きましょう
床と良かったらなんかずっザキヤマいいことなくてさ
1泊まつげてヴァンガードのバックが入っててさ
めっちゃイイ一夢だったわけよ
んでっ
yeah おうえっ
a
これすごい語られレーザーの爪ローソースって言うなんかすごいパラレルねやっぱりの
当たりました
犬のニュー意義を倒すいい
もうもうなぁ3でしょはもうダメだと思う
だからなっひっつけべっ
へメッバッハ
毒とかもっ
汚れついた逆シングルアクション飛行艇者釧路
はっはっは
me
者がちゃうんだよねー狙い通りだってことあまり棒で飽きるということをね
ちょっと遊行やっぱ村すればデュエルするというよりこの開ける時が楽しいいやもう
いいんだよねパッケージのはぜだから今回は ok の後ろの子に2パックですね
まぁこんなもんでしょ愛的で座長ザライドやたキラカードはこちらの5枚です
コーヒーた例や時工程下落しょんウブロ4そのホープレイヴィクトリープラウド
proud プラボ
大ケアを受けパッケージモンスターを抑えが o 邸ではい次行きましょう
キラカードじゃなくて気づかなかったんですけど美容家春休やが2枚入ってました